and we unfortunately living now in this
culture that almost glorifies failure
like its we're supposed to be so happy
Oh fail fast
the average multimillionaire in the US
has seven different sources of income no
life will ever be saved by you
responding to someone who's negative to
you if you help million people you'll
make a million dollars it's the city I'm
going to is so amazing and wonderful
that everyone else wants to be here even
faster than me Warner Brothers we did
all the movie studios that were based in
New York we did all the record labels
based in New York we all have to decide
for ourselves what our individual dream
is because I know you're all going to
write to me and say I can't believe like
my brains like Bradley Cooper and
limitless now if you don't make the
choices in your own life then someone
else is gonna end up making them for you
so I'm good at the writing part I don't
know how to design a hardcover he's an
American hedge fund manager entrepreneur
and author he's founded or co-founded
more than 20 companies USA Today named
his book choose yourself as one of the
top 12 business books of all time he's
James all the Chur and here in his top
10 rules for success I had failed and
succeeded and I started over 20
businesses 17 of them failed and we
unfortunately living now in this culture
that almost glorifies failure like we're
supposed to be so happy oh fail fast fat
it's like this failure pornography
almost that we just like we just worship
people who fail and then somehow succeed
but I could tell you like failure is
really unpleasant and it's much better
to view it as a much better to view it
as like an experiment like Thomas Edison
you know edan fail 10,000 times when
he's making an electric light bulb he
just experimented and then he made an
electric light bulb we don't consider
that the guy was was lying on the street
about to kill himself on the very first
try he tried 10,000 times always have a
plan B so remember and this is all
census data the average multimillionaire
in the US has seven different sources of
income so that means they have Plan B's
all the time so there's never a question
like okay if that was not working like I
had a business that I invested in a lot
of money recently and it wasn't working
but
have Plan B's I have like the seven
other Plan B's so I'm able to say okay
this is bringing me down every time I
talk to you guys I'm not gonna talk to
you anymore unless you have something
good to say to me and I could drop big
they could kick and scream but you put
all this money and I'm like okay I'm
done with that I have Plan B's so all
the time think about how many Plan B's
notice when I had a job at HBO I had a
plan B I had a cut before I left my job
at HBO
I had my company running on the side for
18 months before I left full-time I had
a dozen employees at my company so
always have the plan B's and then it's
easy to leave early in every situation
now again you don't have Plan B's and
relationships there's other things there
you have to be careful of but you know
that's another talk it really can't be
around negative people or people who are
gonna put you down who's gonna put you
down it's not the neighbor down the
street it's your mother or it's true or
it's like your friend or your colleague
like you can't you know and if they want
to engage with you in the negativity you
can't argue them you're like okay you
know I hear you I'm gonna you know eat
my food now or whatever so you know it's
like it's like for instance I see this I
I did a reddit yesterday I reddit AMA
you know one of those thing that's like
a Q&A thing and you see all the time
people are trying to like say negative
stuff just to get you sucked in you see
it on the internet all the time I call
it like internet trolls you know you
never ever respond to any of that
nothing ever good no life will ever be
saved by you responding to someone who's
negative to you so this is very
important then the next step is
obviously surround yourself with
completely positive people who are
inspiring to you or supportive of you
that works very well you need to have
some meaning in your life and so it was
its meaning in your life that causes you
to have ideas that will help people and
that's how you create yeah you know
there's a saying if you help a million
people you'll make a million dollars so
that's the the the dollars is like the
the side effect of helping people first
people have to be helped and then that
means first you have to have to be
really good at coming up with ideas so I
always say you have to have this
the muscle that you exercise regularly
and get it really so you're an idea
machine so that you could then help
people which then in turn helps you
figure out how to make money or you know
you don't even have to figure it out at
that point you'll make money waking up
every morning and figuring out even in a
difficult situation where the pieces of
gratitude are so like coming into the
city yesterday or the day before I was
stuck in traffic and I was late for
something and I was like oh you got to
go faster but this is an opportunity for
a difficult to solve a difficult
gratitude problem which is it's the city
I'm going to is so amazing and wonderful
that everyone else wants to be here even
faster than me so I'm grateful to be
going into this city there were
similarities between all these types of
sales which is you get someone to say
you give ok then you get someone to say
yes so your foots in the door you do
anything you can to get the yes and then
I would always over deliver I kind of
left this part out I would always over
deliver at least initially I would work
so hard to over-deliver just do
something that they didn't expect so for
instance I'll just tell you on stock
picker as an example I the day the deal
was announced today that we officially
launched our partnership I released a
whole new section of the site that they
weren't even expecting which was a QA
kind of like almost like a kora like sub
site within the site and that became
that doubled our traffic almost
overnight they they were completely not
expecting it so I always made an attempt
when I was first building a relationship
and you know all through the
relationship really but it's easiest to
do when you're first building the
relationship is to surprise and delight
like always give extra services so when
I was in the web design business in the
90s we did
Miramax comm new line fine line Warner
Brothers we did all the movie studios
that were based in New York we did all
the record labels based in New York so
we were kind of like our sector was the
entertainment industry and we always no
matter what we always over delivered on
every site that we Specht out every time
we had a meeting with the client there
was always extra things so no
we could ever complain oh this isn't
what we asked for because we always
delivered more and so that was an
important part of being a trusted source
so that people will continue to use our
services on the next sites we all have
to decide for ourselves what our
individual dream is don't subscribe to
some mass hypnosis dream that was
designed to get us to spend as much
money on time on other people's dreams
as possible she was your own dream and
follow that first writing down these 10
ideas a day if you do it for three
months just just try it for three months
you don't have to try it after that
because I know you're all going to write
to me and say I can't believe like my
brains like Bradley Cooper and limitless
now like I can't believe what happened
about now that I'm writing ten ideas a
day down we all the time have have many
choices in life and a great and wise man
once said if you don't make the choices
in your own life then someone else is
going to end up making them for you and
it won't be good so it might be a boss
might be a professor
it might be your parents it might be
colleagues someone else might be a
company someone else is gonna start
making choices for you and they're not
going to be as good as the choices you
can make yourself of course that great
and wise man was myself being very
humble here how do you how do you
execute basically yeah so it's like
you're your brother you have a team you
know you have people who help you you
know this as well as I do like I just
had a book come out Monday so I'm good
at the writing part I don't know how to
design a hardcover I don't know how to
do the interior design I'm not actually
that good at picking the title of a book
I I don't I'm not that great at
marketing I'm I didn't know how to make
an audio book I didn't know how to do
anything
so I outsource every single piece of
that and by the way then I also got a
pre-order of 5,000 copies of the
hardcover to completely pay for all of
the expenses I had on the book so the
book itself to publish it so I
self-published cost $30,000 about give
or take I completely pre-ordered to get
more than that and and then on top of
that I've also
just from the marketing that I out
sourced so to mr. Ryan Holliday who you
know well so does that answer thank you
so much for watching I made this video
because Malik SOOC asked me to so
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
are made of profile next leaving the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I also love to know which of James is
top ten rules meant the most to you will
have the biggest impact on your life or
business leave it in the comments below
and I'll join the discussion and my
personal goal with this channels I hit a
million subscribers so anything you can
think of to share it let people know
about it spread this video I really
really really appreciate it
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you soon